c'est vraiment une mauvaise initiative
vous le pensez vraiment mon pied reçu en
feu
jamais en tant que président de la fed
de l'île aux enfants vous n'auriez dû
accepter l'idée d'un tel concours je
pense que vous avez raison mon cher ami
je crains en effet d'avoir été quelque
peu faible devant l'insistance de
casimir fallu france a besoin du city
stade bonjour j'ai lu bonjour ma très
chère amie ohlala vous m'avez l'air bien
sombres tous les deux dites moi j'espère
que vous ne vous êtes pas disputé devant
nos amis qui viennent d'arriver au
pardon je ne vous avais pas vus bonjour
veuillez me pardonner à mon tour je suis
enchanté de vous voir alors expliquez
moi ce qui vous rend si furieux le
concours quel concours
tu n'es pas au courant non
dites le lui vous même monsieur des
snobs oui et bien notre cher ami c'est
très simple le camp le concours voilà le
concours enfin c'est à dire que le le
concours ça n'a pas l'air très comme l'a
expliqué non pourtant très simple
messieurs du snav a organisé un concours
du plus gros mangeur de l'île aux
enfants sur l'existence de casimir
voyons monsieur du cela vous savez bien
comme il est très mauvais de manger
beaucoup c'est un concours stupide je
sais de plus casimir est assuré d'être
le vainqueur souvenez-vous du ch
concours de choucroute
après la finale le facteur avait dû
rester couchés deux jours mais savait
pas par la digestion ils n'avaient rien
mangé mais c'est vrai
il avait été écoeurée par tous que
casimir l'état pu ajouter dans la
chambre comme un rat cours du mois ça je
ne m'en souviens pas eh bien il avait
rajouté dans la confiture de groseilles
de la crème chantilly dans de la
choucroute des fruits confits mots du
beurre du chocolat des câpres des
cornichons et de la sauce tomate j'ai
arrêté mes chers amis je crois que je
vais me trouver mal moi aussi mais nous
allons monsieur 10,9 il faut être plus
résistants que ça sent simple il
supporterait pas la vie du plaid
kazimiyah mais je regrette mes chers
amis mais cette fois ci il s'agit ni de
choucroute ni deux mélanges bizarres au
répugnant
car il y aura plusieurs catégories par
exemple il y aura une catégorie de
chocolat puis un concours de bananes et
il n'y aura aucun mélange spécial aucun
casimir a dû être très déçu mais non au
contraire m chose mais c'est lui même
car qu'à fixer la liste des différentes
catégories dont je ne me souviens même
plus casimir est lui même voilà qui
n'est pas normal mes amis bonjour je
suis vraiment content de vous voir salut
casimir nous sommes déjà vu ce matin je
sais c'est justement pour me préparer
pour le concours que j'ai besoin de vous
trois de nous trois voilà que tu
inattendue pour quoi faire et bien pour
être sûr de gagner tous les concours il
faut que j'ai très faim alors jouer tu
vas me faire mes exercices de danse je
vais faire un peu de boxe avec toi
françois et une course avec vous
monsieur le store oui ce sera beaucoup
trop kazimi mais oui c'est beaucoup trop
ah bon voilà j'ai compris voix refusé de
m'aider à gagner tous les concours on a
les mains des amis menault que nous
n'avons rien contre toi enfin bon alors
on commence tout de suite aller va vite
lâché les gants de boxe françois et et
vous vous tenu de ce sport là tu voudras
haut niveau je me déteste le plus
possible en fin d'émission
2 1 2 1 2 1 2 elle continue tout seul
tu sais c'est fatigant jolie écoute il
faut que je me dépêche maintenant je je
vais mettre ma tenue de sport
voilà ça va
regarde gauche
droite se percutent crochet tout est
calé le jeune zhang a signalé le jeu du
roi
casimir tenais ma chère à lyon qui nous
regardent et s'il s'agit de la liste des
candidats aux différents concours chez
pâli mais je vous en prie
à vis des habitants
g je suis fatigué mais j'ai très peur ça
marche et une seconde casimir une
seconde d'une peut parcourir avec des
gants de bottes ah oui c'est vrai aulas
tu peux y aller on peut démarrer black
ou alors oser
aller une de plus
[Musique]
voilà
alors quasiment 7 cost convenait tel un
parfait je suis épuisé mais j'ai le feu
le pôle terrible ça marche j'ai fait
j'ai une obsession du snav oui avez-vous
fait bien attention à la liste des
concours avant marchera mirion m'a paru
anormal écoutez premier concours
chocolat oui c'est cela 2e concours
confiture de fraises
troisième baba d'écraser
4e muttart bas et je parie que le 5e
concours concernera les plus gros
mangeurs de saucisse de toulouse cru
mais tiède et comment avez vous deviné
et tous les concours auront lieu en même
temps mais vous êtes un vrai de vin
figurez vous que ce nigaud de casimir
qui a décidé cela et il s'est inscrit
dans tous les concours justement il ne
pourra jamais faire les cinq concours à
la fois et bien le nigaud c'est vous
monsieur des snobs que dites-vous que
casimir rosa bienvenus si vous mélangez
du chocolat en poudre de la confiture de
fraises de la banane écrasée de la
moutarde il la saucisse de toulouse cru
mme etienne vous obtenez du gloubiboulga
le plat préféré de casimir et casimir
affamés devant l oubli boulga géant est
assuré de remporter les cinq concours en
même temps
[Applaudissements]
c'est vraiment incroyable
pire que cela ma chère amie c'est
incompréhensible
tout a disparu je n'ai pu trouver que
ces restes pour faire le concours
dans ces conditions je vois mal qui
pourra empêcher casimir de tout gagner
le voilà justement au
bien du tout son visage est tout pâle
voilà je suis prêt
je crois que j'ai tout compris je crois
que moi aussi très bien nous allons
commencer le concours premier goncourt
le chocolat attention jacques que tu es
prêt font rien les gaz et mirsad ans aux
traits parti
auquel horreur oh non je ne peux pas
très bien jacques becker radioshack
deuxième ne concourra troisième concours
jeunes la confiture de fraises tu es
prêt attention prêts partez
à les gens aller
comme ça non j'y arriverai jamais il y
en a pour les gens bravo jean
troisième concours attention d'alpine la
banane écrasée attention très porté
vers un possible
bravo delphine 4 en cours depuis nos pas
son quatrième concours attention
attention franck la moutarde après
partez
pas comment peut-on manger des choses
pareilles allez france
5 heures
et nous passons au dernier concours la
saucisse de toulouse cru mais tiède
alors attention valérie attention kazemi
après partez allez allez non non non
rien que de voir ça je suis malade
bravo valérie gagnante et valérie
alors casimir
explique-t-on j'avais tellement faim
coûte alors que je mangeais en eau
gigantesques gloubiboulga avec ce que
j'avais préparé pour le concours exacte
et tu es bien unis tu n'a gagné aucun
premier prix en paix mais au fait j'y
pense
nous n'avons pas vu le facteur c'est une
curieuse moi je les rencontre et oui et
quand je lui ai annoncé que nous
préparions un nouveau concours du plus
gros mangeur de l'île aux enfants il m'a
dit gens préfèrent aller me coucher chez
moi et puis il est parti chez lui
kosiner
mais non je vous assure y a pas besoin
d'être un grand écrivain pour être un
poète vous mêmes données lorsque vous
êtes heureux de voir par exemple la
beauté d'une fleur dans les pétales
s'ouvre sous les rayons du soleil ou
lorsque vous vous réjouissez du parfum
du foin fraîchement coupés et bien vous
êtes des poètes
être un poète c'est peut-être tout
simplement
savoir apprécier les choses de la vie
qui nous entourent qu'elle soit gay
qu'elle soit triste
tiens moi georges et lydie dont tu es en
retard et oui je voulais terminer les
rideaux de ma chambre vous êtes en train
de faire un jeu non nous étions en train
de parler de poésie et toi qui connais
beaucoup de poèmes et qu'il ait dit si
bien périlleux pas nous en diront si
pourquoi pas est ce que je vais vous
dire un poème de jacques prévert c'est
une très bonne idée je vais vous dire un
poème de jacques prévert qui est
complètement fou avec des mots sans
queue ni tête ça s'appelle à tue-tête et
à cloche-pied
animant ce brin d'herbe est toute petite
forêt à ciel tout à fait verts et des
nuages ont tous eu une église dans une
malle la malle dans un grenier le
grenier dans la cave sur la tour d'un
château le château à cheval à cheval sur
un gel ou le gène haut dans un sac à
côté d'une rose la rose d'un fraisiers
planté dans une armoire ouverte sur un
show couché dans l'épi d'un miroir sous
les halles d'un tonneau
le tonneau dans un verre dans un verre à
bordeaux bordeaux sur une falaise pour
évincer corpo dans le tiroir d'une
chaise et de chaises en papier en pot
papier de pierre soigneusement taillée
par un tailleur de verre dans un petit
gravier tout au fond d'une main sous les
plumes d'un mouton
nageant dans un lavoir à la lueur d'un
lampion éclairant et 2000 il mine de
crayon derrière une colline
gardé par un drap
groupe d'ados
assis sur la tête d'un jambon
est un jambon de fayots ces puits de
porcelaine qui fait le tour de france à
pied sur une baleine au milieu de la
lune dans un quartier perdu perdu dans
une carafe une carafe d'eau rougis dont
rouge du gala flamme à la flamme d'une
bougie
sous la queue d'une horloge tendu de
velours rouge
dans la cour d'une école au milieu du
désert où de grandes girafes et des
enfants trouvés chante chante sans cesse
à tue-tête à cloche-pied histoire de
s'amuser les mous sans queue ni tête qui
donc ce dans leur texte sans jamais
s'arrêter et on recommence à niveau ses
bras
toute petite forme à gilly c'est un très
joli poème est vraiment tu l'a très bien
dit
voilà casimir c'est dommage qu'il arrive
si tard je suis sûr que ce prévenu
aurait plus sa luge puis françois bon
jeu kazim est assez dommage casimir que
la russie tard tu vas manquer quelque
chose de vraiment formidable ah bon vous
avez mangé un gâteau à la crème
chantilly mais non je l'avais bien fun
de jacques prévert et alors je pense
qu'il ya de formidable
le poème mais c'est impossible pourquoi
impossible parce que la poésie ce n'est
jamais bien tu n'aimes pas la poésie au
nom alors c'est toujours ennuyeux tu ne
te sens jamais l'âme d'un poète toikeuse
et mais moi non heureusement je serais
trop malheureux buggé ski très heureux
un mois et bien par exemple
par exemple quand je vois quand la main
canard faisceau rider long de la mare je
suis heureux quand je vois mes amis
lapin jouer dans la rosée du matin je
suis heureux où caen ou bien quand je
vois une tourterelle traversé l'île
attire audel je suis heureux ou bien
quand vers le soir plus rien ne bouge
quand le soleil s'habille de rouge je
suis heureux voilà tout ce qui me rend
heureux mais c'est très beau casimir
mais sa véritable
casimir ce que deviennent une
véritable poésie comment ils ont
actuellement besoin de la musique des
mots que tu nous l'as dis aux verts je
parle envers moi parfaitement
hormis mais ce n'est pas si le sar et
bien écoute nous allons vérifier tu vas
à redire ce qui te rend heureux ça me
ferait très plaisir de l'entendre une
deuxième fois une très bonne idée julien
et nous nous allons essayer de découvrir
quels sont les rimes il y a dans le
poème de casimir vous êtes d'accord
et bien c'est quasiment rien quand on
canarde fait sourit des longs de la mare
qui a trouvé les rimes
canaris très bien qu'être line canard et
marc os 7 quand je vois mes amis lapin
jouer dans la rosée du matin la femme
est à la taille matin 7
quand je vois une tourterelle traversé
l'île attire audel
alors tourterelles modèle tourterelles
et l on sait que des nues quand vers le
soir plus rien ne bouge que le soleil
sappi de rouge rose
c'est ça en dit long
kambly poussoir
rouge et bouge donc aisé mais c'est
vraiment un très très beau poème en vers
et en plus avec des rimes tu sais on
pourrait l'appeler
ce qui me rend heureux oui mais il ya
quelque chose qui va me rendre encore
beaucoup plus heureux
qu'est-ce que ça eh bien c'est la tête
que va faire monsieur du ch nombre quand
il va apprendre que je suis un grand
poète